[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen studies welt
ich sitze gerade in meiner neuen küche
wir haben uns gerade in esstisch und die
sitzbank dazu ausgesucht nee eigentlich
nur ich sitze gerade in unserer waldigen
küche wir sind noch in der bauphase denn
ich muss es leider gleich am anfang
erwähnen
man hört auf mich gehört und daher hat
sich der bau verzögert um ein halbes
jahr also nicht um sechs wochen oder so
oder um drei monaten ein um sechs monate
und zwar weil er von anfang an nicht auf
mich gehört hat ich wollte ja von anfang
an den architekten haben damit für alle
räume wie so alles hier drei pivot
stelle ich mein erster stelle wo kommt
das wohnzimmer hin und so und der moore
atx verliert ist doch voll übertrieben
das braucht man gar nicht
jetzt im nachhinein wissen wird doch wir
brauchen ich sitze zielgeraden im spiel
habe ich mein abi großer bruder nicht
biologisch großer bruder aber so
großartigen freund von uns und wir sind
gerade da und reden über die
wandgestaltung die haben jetzt
durchgesprochen und läuft
ich mache das wirklich tun dann
geschlossen werden musste schon in ihrer
anbieten egal welcher zwei der toskana
wird nämlich künstler und das mädchen
später glaube ich richtig toll jetzt
laufen noch ein bisschen über den bau
und ich zeige euch einfach mal so ein
bisschen war es und erkläre euch wo der
morath vielleicht ein bisschen was
falsch gemacht hat und wo er hätte
besser auf mich haben sollen
ok also hier in unserer küche und zwar
weil hier später die youtube videos
gedreht
man sieht auch hier am boden zum
beispiel das ist schön abgedeckt da
unten drunter schon sichtbeton also
sieht man auch hier das ist abgedeckt
worden damit einfach nichts beschädigt
wird und da wo die stelle ausgelassen
wurde da kommen die mehr platten rein
also richtig tolle platten die dann auch
zur küche passen und dann stand später
die küchen insel
hier wird schon alles verputzt und bei
unserem haus ist es ja so dass hause da
von außen isoliert das heißt wenn die
feuchtigkeit weg geht kann sie nur noch
innen heraus trocknen und mein papa zum
beispiel der hat ganz gut gemeint und
ging mit dem flammenwerfer an die wände
hier und hat sie versucht zu trocknen
und dann ist es jetzt hat alles
abgeblockt und er hat echt gut gemeint
und wollte das ganze ein bisschen
beschleunigen
aber es muss langsam trocknen nach innen
heraus und jetzt muss hier noch mal
alles verputzt werden befördern das grün
hier die wände eben schön gestalten kann
aber ansonsten muss ich sagen
mittlerweile läuft es läuft zwar
langsamen aber es läuft jetzt gehen wir
mal weiter rüber und gucken mal wer da
noch alles da ist
hier seht ihr zum beispiel die platten
die sind jetzt für meine mama also für
oben für die richtig schöne
landhausküche und die passen echt super
gut und super schön zu meiner mama schön
blau und grau und unsere müssten hier
auch irgendwo sein denn die werden schon
ganz bald verlegt freue ich mich schon
hier rechts und links hat die büroräume
jetzt gucken wir mal was hinten alles
passiert hier sind wir jetzt bei uns im
lager das heißt hier werden wir dann
später unsere ganzen unter grünen bis
zum beispiel verstecken alles was er für
den dreh und für die fotos brauchen hier
wird jetzt alles noch abgekupfert also
dass man einfach diese rohre und so
weiter nicht verputzt ist hier schon
und hier drüben in der garage da wird
jetzt gerade noch verputzt und das hier
zum beispiel dass ich nicht zum
seilspringen gedacht sondern dass die
lautsprecherkabel denn wir bekommen
überall in die decken lautsprecher ein
tier so weit sind sagt garage da kommt
hinter euch noch ein garagentor hin die
türen fehlen natürlich noch und hier
wird jetzt auch gerade noch verputzt und
hier ist einer meiner lieblings ecken
und zwar sind wir hier bei uns im
eingang und hier sitzt endlich auch im
fenster drin ich finde das ist jetzt
natürlich viel viel schöner aus
hier kommt an unsere treppe hin und die
bauen wir damit unserem freund selber
das ist eine stahl holztreppe und der
putz hier ist jetzt gerade mal einen tag
alt man sieht auch schon wieder schön
trocknet und dann kommt man eben aus
diesem bereich direkt in unsere küche
bei uns ist ja alles so ein bisschen
zusammen also küche wohnen essen leben
weist als küche ist hat für unseren
mittelpunkt und ich bin ich ständig in
der küche oder monate stehen ständig in
der küche und hier wird jetzt auch
gerade alles erfolgt auf der baustelle
immer aufpassen und das einzige fenster
was jetzt noch fehlt ist das hier und da
muss ich sagen sind wir natürlich sehr
in verzug also das hat uns wirklich am
meisten aufgehalten
die fenster werden wirklich darauf
geachtet dass wir wirklich von allem das
beste material verwenden und es besser
heißt nicht unbedingt immer das teuerste
also da muss ich einfach sagen dann
immer regionaler hersteller genommen und
lieferanten und wirklich menschen aus
der umgebung um auch hier natürlich die
wirtschaft zu unterstützen
bei den fenstern muss ich sagen haben
wir einfach auf einen bekannten vertraut
und der hat uns die fenster dann besorgt
wir haben alles schon in vorkasse
bezahlt das ist auch der erste tipp den
ich euch geben kann als frau auch der
bau bitte niemals im voraus bezahlen
hört auf eure frauen der um das bessere
bauchgefühl und wir warten schon seit
ungefähr sieben monaten auf die fenster
und das ist jetzt noch das letzte was
fehlt die anderen wurden falsch
geliefert wurden kaputt geliefert und
wurden falsch eingebaut wobei ich sagen
muss dass die
wie man die uns die fenster eingebaut
hat wirklich super war der umzug um
alles gekümmert sauber gearbeitet aber
der der uns die fenster gestellt hat hat
dann die probleme gemacht uns echt auch
sitzen lassen und jetzt haben wir das
fenster woanders bestellen müssen weil
das für einsteiger nicht kommt und
solange die fenster nicht zu sind kann
man natürlich auch nicht weitermachen
also ohne fenster kann man keine kabel
durch zehn nicht verputzen wegen der
feuchtigkeit alles ist offen und es ist
einfach ziemlich blöd also was ich sagen
kann ist auf dem bau immer alles
etappenweise zu bezahlen meine
leistungen erbracht wurde daran teil der
zahl und dann wird erwarten bis der
nächste teil gemacht ist aber ich bin so
langsam wie jetzt was also ich kann mir
schon richtig vorstellen dass da wo ihr
seid vielleicht sofa kommt murat ich
weiß auch noch müssen wir mal gucken
das hätte ich mir alles gerne vorfeld
zur 3d vision vorgestellt aber kriegen
wir schon hin oder kriegen wir hin
hier sind wir jetzt in unserem
arbeitszimmer also neben der küche
direkt und die habe ich zum beispiel so
eine boden steckdose dass ich einfach
auch im schreibtisch mitten in den raum
stellen kann wenn wir überall ihr seht
doch die ganzen verkabelungen werde
überall glasfaser dass wir eben auch das
schnellste internet haben dass ich immer
stehen die videos für euch hochladen
kann und für uns ist natürlich extrem
wichtig weil wir in der digitalen welt
zu hause sind und jetzt will ich sagen
immer hoch hier ist auch schon der
auftritt der ist bei meinen eltern
drüben ist natürlich ganz wichtig wäre
mir hier auch darauf geachtet dass wir
altersgerecht bauen und dann müssen die
nicht ihre einkäufe hoch tragen und auch
später wenn uns alle mit den knien in
der familie ist einfach ein bisschen
einfacher für die ins obergeschoss zu
kommen und hier hinten da haben wir also
den technikraum und im lagerraum für
meinen eltern
ich könnte mir von außen rein manchmal
kann jeder mensch da war zum beispiel
eine truppe mal hallo was hier drüben
gemacht wird hat auch hier seht dass zum
beispiel auch dass die türen etwas
breiter sind als sie breiter als unsere
standard türen so hat man später auch
einfacher wenn zum beispiel ein
rollstuhl machen müsste oder
dann gucke eben auch besser die türen
rein hier bei meiner mama treffen haben
wir zum beispiel risse in der wand
bekommen also setzrisse und es kann
natürlich mal passieren dabei ist
natürlich der vorteil dass wir länger
gebraucht haben denn die risse sind erst
vor drei wochen entstanden das heißt
wenn schon alles verputzt und tapeziert
gewesen
er ist natürlich ein problem jetzt kann
man es noch schnell reparieren und es
ist auch gar nicht schlimm auf dem bau
hat man eben so was und kann man was
schiefgehen unseren setzungsrisse muss
ich sagen ist nicht so schlimm
vor allem jetzt muss sowieso noch mal
verschickt werden kann und hier oben
seht ihr schon das gerüst für die decke
die wird ein bisschen abgehängt da
kommen noch die lautsprecher reihen und
das gerüst steht schon mal die lichter
also die kabel seht ihr schon für die
spots und ich wollte halt immer ganz
gern dass das zu hause schön hell ist
dass man wirklich viel licht oder finde
ich led-spots einfach am besten sind ja
auch energiesparend und ich finde es
immer schön wenn man tag es nicht zu
hause hat kommt wahrscheinlich auch
daher dass wir tag natürlich selber
filmen und alles helfe mich ist aber ich
fühle mich dann irgendwie auch mona oder
sie hat immer aus als hätte man im
sonnenlicht in der wohnung auch wenn es
dunkel ist
ich glaube jetzt geradeaus zum ihres
zimmers war hier in oder das ist hier in
der ecke und hier war ursprünglich unser
balkon das war da wo ich letztes mal
euch herausgefunden habe und jetzt haben
wir uns doch dazu entschlossen hierzu zu
machen weil ich ein problem damit habt
dass die kinder oben einen eigenen
balkon haben also ich glaube ich könnte
einfach familie und ella nie alleine
oben auf den balkon lassen hätte ein
bisschen angst dass sie über das gerüst
unser weiter klettern und deswegen damit
dass jetzt hierzu gemacht ich auch so
schön hat so ein bisschen wintergarten
feeling mit viel licht alles ist voller
fenster und deswegen haben als auch über
dass wir hier offen lassen und
wahrscheinlich wird das sowas wie unsere
leser erklärte machen wir dann unsere
büchereien die einsam ihre hausaufgaben
machen usw und nimmt dann einfach das
zimmer gegenüber was eigentlich ein
gästezimmer war
denn gestern können wir auch hier im
prinzip unterbringen und so hat man
schönen hobbyraum mit dabei und so ein
bisschen versammlungsraum am abend und
ich denke kann man so ein bisschen
besser nutzen als den balkon retten
irgendwie draußen nur verstaubt und
nicht genutzt wird
die auf dem boden seht ihr übrigens auch
die rohre für die zentrale staubsauger
anlage und die haben wir letzte woche
mit meinem bruder hier verlegt da können
wir mal reinschauen
jetzt zeige ich euch hier im
obergeschoss wie wir die rohre für die
zentralen strafsache anlage installieren
im plan haben wir eingezeichnet wo dies
auch dosen hinkommen und wie viele wir
hier oben benötigen
da guckt mir einfach nach der schlauch
länge und dann ebenso wenig lösen wie
möglich und es wird auch bei uns von der
firma thomas einmal überprüft und dann
haben uns überlegt sowie legen wir jetzt
hier diese rohre hin
und die haben wir jetzt einmal ganz
kopien gelegt und zwar macht man das so
dass man einfach die kürzesten weg
gehabt und die so hinlegt wie es eben
auch passt also ich zeige euch das jetzt
hier einmal geht man mit also hier
liegen diese ht rohre und zwar führt
jetzt dieses eine hier zum beispiel hier
ins bad weil wir ja im bad so einen
kleinen schacht haben wo wir dann mit
dem fuß dagegen treten kann wo man unten
die haare wissen einkehren kann hier
unten haben wir dann wieder eine dose
und so muss man einfach raum durchgehen
und wirklich diese woche auf dem boden
hinlegen und die legt man sich hinsetzt
sie dann gleich zurecht und dann kann
man eben auch schauen wie viel material
man benötigt und so weiter und je kürzer
die wege sind umso besser denn unsere
weniger ware müsst ihr hier auch eben
verlegen und jetzt zeige ich euch mal
wie man die zusammensteckt mit hilfe des
lesers hier konnten wir uns präsentiert
diese linie zeichnen lassen so dass die
hat er auch kerzengerade makurath liegen
ich bin am ende sieht man das sowieso
nicht unter dem fußboden argument mutter
da will immer alles ganz genau bei dem
was alles ganz exakt sein alles
kerzengerade abgemessen bis zu jedem
kleinsten millimeter
deswegen war das hier schon ganz gut und
jetzt muss ich gucken dass ich die auch
kerzengerade hin lebt sonst kriegt ärger
von nehmen alle hatte ihr eure liegen
jetzt und sind abgemessen
und jetzt kann ich sie zusammen stecken
ich mache es auch so dass wir sie auch
zusammenkleben denn der estrich kommt
jetzt nicht sofort und damit andere
handwerker und auch wir hier nicht
drüber stolpern und die rohre aus
versehen wieder aufgehen müssen wir sie
festkleben
damit man sie jetzt überhaupt gut
zusammen stecken kann braucht mal an
gleitgel man kann aber auch da zum
beispiel spülmittel verwenden
und jetzt kommt hier ein kleines
bisschen was rein und dann könnte das
mit dem finger so ein bisschen verreiben
und ohne gleitgel oder spüle kann man es
halt nicht zusammen stecken und dann
geht es zusammen stecken wirklich super
einfach so und jetzt nehme ich hier
klebeband und kann es hier
zusammenkleben
[Musik]
und hier zum beispiel diese typische
ecke und haben hier einfach diesen
winkel rein geklebt und da muss ich
jetzt auch auf der anderen seite einfach
gut zusammen kleben
[Musik]
die zweite natürlich meine erste
überlegung okay wenn sanierer in ihrem
zimmer bügel perlen aus lehrt ausgesät
und wir sie weg saugen
dann saugt wird das praktisch aus ihrem
zimmer heraus durch den ganzen flur am
besten macht durchs schlafzimmer runter
in den technikraum und dafür damit eben
keine geräusche entstehen haben wir
diesen schlauch das ist nämlich die
dämmung und so kommen geräusche erst gar
nicht zustande und den schlaf bekommt
ihr am besten durch drehende bewegungen
rum
und die dämmung zieht man hier einfach
über das wort rüber und so für die das
spiel einfach fort und bei der nächsten
schwierigen stelle zeige ich euch noch
mal ein paar tipps das war zwar das land
gehen
[Musik]
die haben wir jetzt so eine schwierige y
stelle und da ist natürlich schwierig
den schlauch einfach so drüber zu ziehen
daher braucht es die schere und müsst
hier wie bei einem rock sondern schlitz
neu machen
mai machen reinmachen und vorher
natürlich die dämmung hier hoch ziehen
dann zusammen charmant zusammenstecken
wieder mit gleitgel und jetzt kann ich
das rohr von rechts und links
zusammenstecken wieder kleben
jetzt kennt die dämmung einfach drüber
ziehen und auch fest leben
[Musik]
und genau so machen wir jetzt hier
weiter bis alles fertig ist
[Musik]
er sagte mal gesehen wie weit wir ihnen
schon sind hier außen sieht irgendwie
unverändert aus ich glaube wenn man hier
vorbei fertigen oder mensch diese idee
wird und mir dann wird einfach nicht
fertig das problem mit den fenstern
haben wir jetzt überwunden weil das
einfach woanders gestellt haben hier
draußen geht es jetzt auch endlich
weiter sobald es ein fensterelement noch
geliefert wird damit nämlich die fassade
gemacht und zeit bei ich sage mir dann
auch schon mit dem garten an da haben
wir auch schon eine planung gemacht und
wirklich alles richtig toll geplant
dieses mal datum murat auf mich gehört
und ja ich denke es wird demnächst alles
parallel so ein bisschen fertig wir
müssen jetzt natürlich schon anfangen
und möbel anschauen
wir waren jetzt auch letzte woche schon
im möbelhaus und haben so ein bisschen
geschaut
man muss sich natürlich überlegen in
welche stilrichtung geht man murat
findet zum beispiel das bei meinen
eltern und ich auch dass da der
landhausstil ganz gut reinpassen würde
es passt einfach zu meinen eltern so ein
bisschen blümchen und die weißen möbel
und so weiter gardinen passen auch
superschön
bei uns daheim sind so ein bisschen
uneinig morath sagt immer shabby chic
style gefällt ihm ganz gut da gibt es
auch im internet ganz ganz ganz viele
anregungen die man sich da wirklich
holen kann
was auch schön ist ist ein industries
teil daher hatten wir auch diesen
sichtbeton boden aber der sichtbeton
boden der ist ja total neutral also man
kann wirklich alles machen und edler
stil ist auch toll
vielleicht könnt ihr uns da einfach ein
bisschen helfen ich muss jetzt mal so
machen sonst sehe ich jetzt gleich
nichts mehr um blind vielleicht habt ihr
doch noch ein paar ideen welche
stilrichtungen kennt ihr was wird zu uns
geheim was wird zu uns passen wärme
ansicht betonboden unten oben wollen wir
ein dunkles parkett verlegen die fenster
sind anthrazit also die rahmen und ja
vielleicht habt ihr einfach ideen für
uns und könnt uns hier unten war es in
die kommentare reinschreiben
ich hoffe ich hoffe wirklich sehr dass
ich ganz bald wieder ein update machen
kann
in drei wochen soll die küche geliefert
werden dh die männer da drinnen die
müssen richtig hart arbeiten jetzt mein
bruder ist demnächst mit den kabeln
fertig der droschken macht die wende
da helfe ich auch mit bei der gestaltung
werden da ganz viele tolle ideen die
küche kommt rein und da können wir
wahrscheinlich schon ganz ganz bald
hoffe ich
ja auch unsere videos drehen für euch
ich hoffe euch hat dieses update
gefallen
falls ja auch gerade beim bau seid lasst
euch nicht entmutigen und macht einfach
weiter fehler passieren auf dem bau
immer und es gibt immer jemanden das
besser weiß und ich glaube auch
schlimmsten sind die die dann auf den
bau kommen und sagen mensch hier habt
ihr fehler und da habt ihr fehler
es passiert einfach und ihr braucht
einfach menschen um mich herum die euch
weiterhin ermutigen und bleibt am ball
ich wünsche euch viel spaß noch bei
diesem tollen wetter ich werde jetzt die
kinder bei meinen eltern holen und dann
gehen wir noch ein bisschen an die
frische luft vielleicht den tierpark ein
paar enten füttern und dann schauen wir
mal was noch passiert heute also bis zum
nächsten mal und ich warte auf jeden
fall auf eure ideen rund um den stil für
uns zu hause
[Musik]